le département et antenn Réunion vous
présente lien
[Musique]
social c'est à la jonction des bas et
des haut au 19e km au tampon que se
cache un vestige à la fois naturel et
historique le domaine archambau fait
partie des espaces naturels sensibles
gérés par le département asite de plus
d'un hectare qui abrite les ruines d'une
maison créole traditionnelle et une
petite portion de forêt primaire un
projet de réhabilitation prévoit la
rénovation prochaine du site et sa
valorisation touristique mais les
visiteurs peuvent déjà découvrir
l'histoire et les richesses de ce
[Musique]
lieu donc bienvenue Bienvenue sur sur
cette espace naturel sensible hein qui
connaît le mot le nom archambau le N
archambau c'est pas un inconnu archambau
pierreedouard Augustin archambau ce
Saint-Pierrois né à la fin du 19e siècle
est élu deux fois maire de la ville en
1902 et en 1926 près d'un siècle plus
tard on retrouve les vestiges de son
existence alors Monsieur archambau à une
époque il s'est dit bah pourquoi pas
aller dans les eau pour faire une case
de villigature à l'époque c'était à la
mode celui qui avait des moyens il
pouvait se permettre d'avoir une case
changement d'air c'est donc au 19e à la
Plaine des Cafres que subsiste le
domaine archambau longtemps la à
l'abandon le département fait
l'acquisition du site en
1996 aujourd'hui vous voyez la maison
qui est très véuste hein avec la rouille
qui qui a commencé à attaquer et même
pierre auor plus de 75% de la structure
est abîmé la collectivité travaille donc
sur un projet de réhabilitation du site
notamment de la bâtise principale ce
sont des bâtiments qui font l'objet
d'une déconstruction totale et d'une
réhabilitation en tenant compte bien sûr
des ouvrages structurels nécessaires à
la valorisation du site en lui-même il
conviendra par contre d'aménager en
l'état et bien le site pour permettre
aussi aux personnes à mobilité réduite
d'avoir accès au site sans aucune
difficulté l'objet de la démarche
consiste à la fois à valoriser les haut
à travers un patrimoine existant mais
également à mettre en place des services
pour les usagers sur un site
emblématique et qui est donc le domaine
archambau mais ce qui rend ce lieu
exceptionnel ce sont surtout ces
extérieurs la demeure se situe dans un
jardin de plus d'un hectare je vais vous
emmener en forêt on va parler
conservation
d'environnement à la lisière du domaine
une petite forêt renferme des trésors de
la nature ici vous avez retrouvé des
plantes qui sont des haau et des bas
voilà c'est une forêt de transition si
vous voulez le site abrite un
échantillon de forêt primair qui
regroupe des espèces indigènes et
endémique le domaine fait partie des
espaces naturels sensibles du
département le lieu est géré par le
groupement pour la conservation de
l'environnement et de l'insertion
professionnelle c'est par vous même vous
allez découvrir c'est quoi cette PL
c'est quoi les critère on va on va le
faire ensemble l'objectif pour nous
c'est qu' une réappropriation de ce
patrimoine là par la population tant
qu'à faire s'il est accessible c'est
tant mieux donc archau c'est très
accessible et l'occasion pour nous de
montrer justement les espèces indigè
endémiques ce milieu particulier de
forêt de de moyen altitude quand on est
en forêt tropicale on voit toujours des
mousses des des orchidées des
Lian et par contre Chang corses en
général il y a pas grandchose
pourquoi parce qu'il change des Corses
on essaie en tout cas de de porter le
message de la protection d'environnement
si on est respectueux si on est
altruiste si on veut partager les choses
forcément contribuera donc à la
protection deenvironnement un message
auquel sont sensibles les visiteurs du
jour pour la plupart grands amateurs de
plantes le domainechambo je connaissais
pas donc c'est une découverte pour moi
et puis ben il y a plein de plantes
endémiques et moi je suis une fana des
plantes endémiques donc c'était pas
faire un petit peu tout ce que je connaî
approfondir un peu c'est un c'est un
petit domaine qui est assez riche en en
diversité végétal donc qui est
intéressant pas mal d'espèces qui sont
regroupées là donc c'est c'est pas mal
du tout le projet de réhabilitation
prévoit également de transformer
l'ancien boucan en miellerie pédagogique
ces travaux au profit du tourisme local
devrait commencer début 2017 pour le
département il s'agit de répondre à une
logique de valorisation intelligente de
ses actif c'est un projet pédagogique
c'est un projet humain c'est un poumon
vert dans le département aujourd'hui a
comme mission de remettre en valeur et
de permettre justement d'avoir sur les
miipantes de la Réunion les miipantes du
Sud
d'avoir un espace d'accueil présentation
et en même temps développer
l'apiculture développer la
sensibilisation aux abeilles aux forêts
primaires et aussi aux espèces
endémiques de la
[Musique]
Réunion le domaine archambau est un site
patrimonial situé au 19e km au tampon il
comprend une maison créole du 19e siècle
et un terrain de plus d'un hectare qui
abrite une forêt primaire le lieu fait
partie des espèces naturelles sensibles
gérées par le Département des visites
guidées sur le domaine sont possibles
sur rendez-vous la visite dure 3h et
coûte 5 € par personne pour plus
d'informations ou pour réserver une
visite vous pouvez contacter le
Conservatoire d'espace naturel de la
réunion au 06 92 65 29 40 ou vous rendre
sur le site du département au
www.cg974.fr I